what's going on guys today we're going
to be theorizing what it would be like
if there were ten titan shifters in the
world of attack on titan
for most of this series the amount of
titans was a complete mystery and it
wasn't until the end of season three
that we got confirmation there were nine
of them in total
my personal theory as to why isaiah
didn't make more is because the way the
story was set up by the time they
reached the basement
we already knew the parodies didn't have
more shifters so if there were going to
be 10 11 or even 12 of these things
by default the rest would have all been
malian warriors doing that would have
made mali way too overpowered especially
during the battle in liberio
so it was a good decision by isayama to
not make things even more difficult for
the scouts
that being said though it's still fun to
think about what features a 10-shifter
might have had and in this video i'll be
doing exactly that by discussing a titan
that i think would have been a realistic
addition to the series
the main idea behind this one is that it
has a special connection to the
coordinate that gives it certain
abilities
and as the title suggests its name would
be the past titan
after the video is done let me know in
the comments how you think it ranks
compared to the others
and don't forget to hit that sub button
if you want to see more videos like this
okay so starting with a brief
description of what paws are in the
first place
they are the abstract force that
connects the coordinate to every elegant
on the planet
and in the past dimension this force is
represented by branches of light
all subjects of emir are born with their
own path that links them to the founding
titan
hence why historically the founder has
been able to mess with aliens in so many
ways
including wiping their memories or
sending the flesh and bones that would
turn them into a titan
besides this very few shifters can
interfere with pars or the past
dimension
so if a 10th one existed that is pretty
much exactly what it would do
standing at 50 meters tall i imagine the
past item would be mostly covered in a
thin protective shell of hardening
with its most distinctive feature being
its mask this mask would remain in place
most of the time unless the shifter was
about to scream
at which point it can be detached
similar to how rhino can selectively
unharden parts of the armored titan
over the years we've seen that screaming
can be used for different purposes and
for the past titan it would have two
screams that would be its most important
abilities
its first screen would literally be able
to interrupt other people's titan
transformations
meaning their titles will end up being
incomplete or the victim would just
remain in their human form
aaron once mentioned how the flesh of a
titan is sent via pods
well this shifter screen can block that
signal and make it so the titan body
never reaches the destination in this
way the paths can prevent both shifters
and pure titans from manifesting
but the scream has to occur before they
completely transform
if we use an easy example to see how
this could work in practice let's
imagine the user of the past titan was
with these guys during the declaration
of war
in that scenario it would not have been
able to stop aaron's first
transformation
since he didn't know it was about to
happen and if it did scream it likely
would have been way too late
what it could do though is prevent aaron
from transforming a second or third time
which is what he did in the main series
and by doing this the attack titan would
at best only partially manifest
a royal blooded founder is the only
shifter who would be unaffected by this
ability
but for everyone else including royals
like zeke there's nothing they can do to
get around this
moving on to the past titan's second
scream this one would be a twist on the
ability to create pure
titans as it has a big benefit but also
a big cost at the same time
the benefit is that any ld within range
of the scream can be turned into a pure
titan
without the need to first consume spinal
fluid if we look at the main series
whenever z wanted to make pure titans he
needed to make sure they first ingested
his spinal fluid in some form
because that fluid is what connected
them to the beast titan when it comes to
the past titan though
it doesn't have to do this because it
has a special connection to the
coordinate
which by proxy implies it has a faint
connection to every elden as well
ultimately what that means is that
aliens within range of the scream will
be turned into mindless titans with
acumens and other shifters being the
only ones who are naturally immune
the pure titans that are created can
then be controlled depending on if the
user of the past titan has royal blood
and this is where we come to the
downsides if a person without real blood
has the shifter
their number one the titans they create
will try to kill them and number two
they have no control over which aliens
will be turned into pure titans
what that second point means is that if
a regular alden uses the shifter
the screen will indiscriminately
titanize everyone in the area including
any ldn friends they have who might
happen to be nearby
this effect also can't be undone by the
past titan's first screen
as like i said that power doesn't work
after transformation is already complete
now on the other hand if the past titan
is held by someone of royal blood
they can select which people they don't
want to be transformed and any pure
titans they make will automatically
follow their instructions
other powers of this shifter include the
ability to summon one ld into the past
dimension
regardless of where that person might be
in the real world this telepathy
requires a bit of stamina it can
therefore only be used once a day
but it's still a great thing for
long-range communication because if you
think about it if someone had this
during the invasion of parodies
they would have been able to provide
updates to their fellow warriors back
home without anyone on the island
knowing a thing
on a separate note as many of you know
time passes a lot differently in the
past dimension
so what might feel like hours or even
days in there might only be equivalent
to a few seconds in reality
this not only means that the past titan
can have long conversations with someone
else
but in theory they could also use this
power to temporarily confuse their
enemies
as an example let's say mikasa was about
to attack the shifter but as she gets
closer her mind is sent to the past
dimension for what feels like hours
by the time she comes back to reality
she'll be heavily disorientated
and likely won't follow through with
what she was about to do in this way
this tactic could very effectively be
used to throw people off their game
but like i said it can only be used once
a day i should probably also mention
that despite being connected to every
eldian the past titan is not able to
manipulate memories in any way
but rather it's forced to see the
memories of every pure titan it touches
i consider this to be more of a curse
than a blessing as by making physical
contact the past titan has no choice but
to see flashes of what their life used
to be
there's nothing it can do to help them
besides that as it can't turn them back
into a human once they're already
transformed
so it's basically like being forced to
watch a really sad movie whenever it
happens to touch a minus titan
last point to mention before we
summarize all of its abilities is that
this shifter has a maximum of three
consecutive transformations
which is more than the colossal which
maxes out one but still the exact same
as the attack titan
anyway in summary the past titan has two
distinct screams
one that prevents the transformation of
other titans and another that creates
titans without the need for spinal fluid
injections
if the user doesn't have real blood then
doing that second scream is effectively
suicide but if they are royalty then
they can create their own personal titan
army that listens to their commands
once a day the shifter can also summon
one ld to the past dimension
which is useful for both confusing
opponents and for long-range
communication
sadly though the past titan cannot
access or manipulate memories but
instead is forced to see the past
memories of every pure titan it
physically touches
additionally skin is mostly covered in
thin hardening which gives it a constant
layer of protection
and in my opinion that has a great
chance against every shifter except
these two in a fight
as always guys thank you for watching
this video and let me know in the
comments how do you think the past item
would do in a 1v1 fight against the
other shifters
also don't forget to sub and until the
next one peace out